The most widely used approach to
encrypt a large message is CBC.
It stands for cipher block chaining.
In CBC, the input to the encryption
algorithm is the result of
xoring the previous ciphertext block and
the current plaintext block.
To encrypt the first plaintext block,
we use a so-called IV,
stands for initialization vector.
And we XOR IV with
the plaintext block and
give the input to the encryption process
to produce the first ciphertext block.
And then the first ciphertext
block is used to XOR with
the second plaintext block as
input to the encryption process
to produce the second ciphertext
block and so on so forth.
Again in CBC,
the current ciphertext block depends
not only on the current plaintext block
but also the previous ciphertext block.
Which in turn depends on not only
the previous plaintext block but
also the ciphertext block prior to that.
In other words, in analysis
it is very hard to figure out
the plaintext block just looking
at the current ciphertext block.
More importantly, if two plaintext
blocks are exactly the same,
meaning that they repeat in the same
message or in two different messages,
their ciphertext blocks
are not likely to be the same.
In addition, if an attacker attempts to
swap in a different ciphertext block or
rearrange the orders of
the ciphertext blocks,
the ciphertext is not going to
decrypt properly into the plaintext.
Here's how decryption in CBC works.
A ciphertext block is decrypted,
and then the result is XORed with
the previous ciphertext block to
produce the current plaintext block.
For the first ciphertext
block after decryption,
the result is XORed with Iv to
produce the first plaintext block.
Therefore, the Iv must be known
to both the sender and receiver.